so
no Emma is downsizing as a motor
downsizing maintaining power with lower
engine displacement there's an important
topic in car making says our car tester
Adelaide cinema there are still skeptics
who think there is no substitute for
cubic capacity and that downsized
engines are closer to air pumps that
engines the cutting edge of downsizing
is currently a 1-liter 3-cylinder engine
and a turbocharger and that's the engine
in the premium compact car will test
drive today the Audi a3 past us ankush
to them
there's nothing unusual about the engine
sound the one point o tfsi engine is
part of the a3's facelift counting the
s-class model the new a3 comes in nine
different engine variants the three
cylinder with 85 kilowatts is the least
powerful fuel consumption is four and a
half liters per 100 kilometers so the
three cylinder is the 50s gasoline
engine for the a3 poppin diet salontoday
says there's only one way to see whether
a three-cylinder engine is as bad as
some say step on the gas I won't as
always well the performance isn't
exactly an adrenaline rush but this
isn't a sports car it's the entry-level
model and the power is adequate for
everyday use the three-cylinder a3 takes
nearly ten seconds to accelerate to 100
kilometers an hour the shifting is done
by an S tronic 7-speed automatic our
test car cost just over twenty six
thousand euros in Germany
as a bamboo flooring Andre says you
might expect a three-cylinder engine to
vibrate loudly but that's not the case
it's a bit rough when you accelerate but
it's surprisingly quiet when you cruise
along of course the engineers know what
weaknesses a three-cylinder is prone to
and need to be counteracted pathan Dre
sees no disadvantage in the missing four
cylinder well gee I've never kiss a
patent gigabytes it as well you see that
kind of knock Tyler in Finland celinda
the revision of the a3 has changed some
things inside and out the package with a
sat-nav and virtual cockpit costs around
3,000 euros it presents all the
important information within the
driver's sight additional assist systems
are available including the traffic jam
assistant
the new light design of the exterior is
really eye-catching matrix LED
headlights are optional the lower part
of the bumper has also been revised
alterations in the rear are more subtle
Monday stink the smaller engine means
less sportiness is Andre but the rest of
the car isn't slack the steering is well
adjusted and direct the suspension is
tight enough to take curves fast and
smoothly it's fish for mystical vankin
with the revised a 3 out he offers its
customers more individual choices many
optional features for example the matrix
LED lights and the three-cylinder engine
are new for Audi compacts but not for
compacts in general opals current Astra
for example already offered them here
audi is playing catch-up
so look to my Andre says the Audi
three-cylinder engine works fine it's
not too loud and makes no dent and
driving comfort it's not a fast
accelerator and not terribly sporty but
Andre says if you're worried about
downsizing and three cylinder engines
the best thing to do is to take such a
car out for a test drive and see for
yourself the downsizing and Jiang's Ford
right cylinder motor on desert manam
best I for my engine demons eyeballs pop
yet
smoking tires roaring engines and
lightning fast pit stops that's par for
the course at the 24-hour race staged a
Germany's famous Nurburgring track but
this year the teams also had to deal
with extreme weather conditions heat
torrential rain and hail pushed manna
machine to their limits the Matilda
racing team was in the thick of things
owner Michelle Potts explains how the
team got it's unusual name manama Oviatt
one night they were chatting over a beer
when his daughter Matilda was a year old
he couldn't think of anything clever and
teams all have racing in their names so
he thought let's use my daughter's name
and until the racing was born I think
from Matilda is now seven years old the
racing paddock has become her second
home that's cool
she likes watching the cars go around
the Matilda racing team works closely
with say OTT and helps with development
work during the 24 hour race a few CI
mechanics have come especially from
Spain to lend a hand it's transnational
teamwork
the coordination is very good so I think
there's a very good workout together
experience from said sport and the will
to the world with Matilda is a good
combination then it's time to head for
the starting area for the 24 hour race
teams drivers and spectators flock here
to get a last look at the cars Matilda
has come to see your father and exactly
3 30 p.m. some 160 cars get off to a
flying start they'll tackle the infamous
nordschleife a route that's close to 25
kilometers long not long afterwards hail
and blinding rain turned the racetrack
into a slip and slide one vehicle after
another flies off the track and into the
barriers it's the end of the 24 hour
race for some and it looks that way for
one of Matilda's racing seats too
nob treat driver andreas gordon says
after the shrine coydt's bend enroute to
arabic there is a corner on a little
hill top but on the hill where he should
have been able to see the racetrack
again he just saw a huge lake a river
and it caught him by surprise floss on
Don Smith uncut i wished luckily for him
the race is halted for around three
hours in the meantime the mechanics are
able to repair enough of the damage to
get the car back in the race
right on schedule the crew once again
brings the fixed up seeit to the
starting line
even Matilda helps however she can
when I saw the car Christ in the in that
corner heavily cries with one wheel
missing I said that's it we go home and
not even we raise that we didn't lose
any luck so only some positions that we
managed to get them in the first thing i
did so it was incredible experience in
spite of the awful weather the race
starts again in the early evening
Matilda and the pit crew look on as
their team race to catch up
unfortunately just one of the two
ciothes make it through the night the
other was taken out by another car why
our Klaus needs vez says they've been
hampered by accidents first by heavy
rains and hailstorms with a 201 and then
his car the 202 got hit and is beyond
repair shops will atleast marathon
despite losing one of their cars the
race is thrilling right to the end the
remaining SIA with a starting number 201
even finishes first in its class
right until the final rounds the leaders
in the major vehicle classes battle it
out for the overall victory it's a
neck-and-neck race the victor in his
class Michelle Potts is very pleased
yeah I'm does that I specimen he says
they've achieved their goal to show that
a see oddly on TCR can handle the
Nordschleife and be a contender in the
24-hour race at the Nurburgring they're
proud to have crossed the finish line
and won their class everything's great
ultram ta âlâ sofa mankato Matilda likes
to learn things from her dad does she
plan to follow in his footsteps one day
she doesn't know yet but she might
become a racecar driver till then she'll
keep cheering her father on from the
pits
volkswagen has a new amarok out on the
roads with a new 3-liter v6 TDI engine
the tough brawny exterior underlines its
powerful performance but if you want one
this year you'll have to buy the more
expensive launch edition the aventura
for around fifty five thousand euros in
Germany the basic model starts at thirty
thousand six hundred euros and a set for
release in early 2017 following the
sedan Mercedes now presents its eClass
as a station wagon three choices of
four-cylinder engines will be available
for the market lunch followed by a
six-cylinder diesel and a gasoline
version at the end of the year with a
capacity of around 1800 litres the trunk
space is the biggest in the segment the
new e-class will be available in
dealerships in fall
beg also ensure that if you have to
transport large heavy loads you need big
wheels as our car tester michelle austyn
maha that was true for the old hay
wagons and it hasn't changed for this
lexus rx450h with a curb weight of more
than 2 tons large wheels are clearly
justified in the front LED headlamps
provide a clear view this hybrid SUV has
18 leds and its rear lights that blink
in sequence the back seats fold down at
the push of a button to expand trunk
space to around 1600 liters
the income of the interior design is
very exclusive Michelle especially likes
the two-tone leather whether it's
recessed red seems but she says there
are so many buttons that you need some
time to find the one you're looking for
the chassis of the lexus rx450h is quite
angular and modern in design with its
flat lights and large Diablo radiator
grille typical for Lexus the car seems
almost menacing the H at the end of its
name stands for hybrid despite its size
this car is almost silent the
combination of electric motor and v6
gasoline engine gives this luxury SUV a
total of 230 kilowatts so despite its
weight it accelerates from 0 to 100 and
7.7 seconds the electric motor keeps
fuel consumption down to five point
three liters per 100 kilometers defeat a
homeless legs Michelle says the
suspension is very soft and the car is
designed overall for comfort comfort is
indeed the focus of the RX 450 to spite
its sporty exterior the hybrid drive
contributes to this because the quiet
start and direct power transmission
quickly get the Lexus going with a 2.7
meter wheelbase the Lexus provides a lot
of room various modifications reduce
noise for example new materials on the
wheel arches and reduce gaps in the
acoustic insulation the engineers have
also optimized the aerodynamics for
example with a newly shaved spoiler at
the end of the roof
thus designers Lexus the design of the
lexus rx450h won't be everyone's taste
but Michelle likes it she regards it as
a city car despite its size because its
fuel economy is greater at low speeds
than on country roads or highways lunch
class Senora Autobahn that's because the
car is powered purely electrically when
starting and up to about 30 kilometers
an hour but on country roads a speed of
70 or 100 is maintained solely with the
gasoline engine in schizont Michelle
says she can well imagine using the
Lexus for long distance trips but then
it ought to have a diesel engine and
currently Lexus doesn't have that
available that's not likely to change
soon because with more than 2 million
our X's sold worldwide this is the
best-selling model in the 26-year
history of lexus
black rubber in all different shapes and
sizes stands proudly on display at this
tire fair in essen western Germany 675
exhibitors from 43 countries have come
to show their wares
bridgestone has upgraded their drive
guard run-flat tires as well as their
ability to perform when punctured these
tires can now be recycled often compost
unfortunately they can't just be thrown
on the compost explained Sebastian grim
from Bridgestone but they're working on
that the tire can be completely recycled
though under the same process as normal
tires goodyear is exploring entirely new
dimensions with their cutting-edge
spherical tires the eagle 360 is a
concept tire for self-driving cars and
it doesn't only move in three dimensions
it's manufactured using 3d printing
awesome gay exceeds love it I'm cut from
Goodyear points out that the ball shape
grabs your attention straight away
because it's so different from
conventional tires it uses magnets to
suspend the car over the tires it's the
same principle as in a magnetic
levitation train that's the driving
force behind it electromagnets enormous
David thinks these tires would have an
enormous advantage because they're
multi-directional and therefore have
better maneuverability if they can steer
at a 90 degree angle which would be
great for parking Ondine focus that's to
Falcon it's a mosh pit and that extra
flexibility means cars can be parked
closer together and spaces can be used
more efficiently you can get all the
necessary information about a tire using
your smartphone a QR code provides a
digital profiler of the tire created by
four jet technologies the company spent
nine months developing them and the
system works for car and truck tires
yaad echoecho Tim Eyman call says QR
codes will be supplied with tires as
standard in the next few years and he
sees many advantages for example you can
be certain you have the correct tires
for your car you can also get
information that might not be obvious
just by looking at the tires in the
future the QR code could link us to an
online shop to buy tires directly so we
know we're getting the right ones phys
on ultra ball from a comp directory
listing and Photoshop Z tire is a new
manufacturer of premium high performance
tires and here they're presenting a
model that's so valuable that has to be
kept in a glass case this tire is
diamond-encrusted and costs around 150
thousand dollars let's even in the
Guinness Book of Records as the most
expensive tire of all time and it's
truly unique
now I'm telling him did everybody this
is a one-off production sesh stefan
known guest from z tire and was made in
italy in a large diamond studio a full
set of tires would cost you six hundred
thousand dollars stefan tells us this
tire has already been sold to an arabian
businessman who wants it for his vehicle
collection daddy for sign a fat [ __ ]
some lanka kofta this tire changing
machine is called uniformity and at one
corgi the manufacturer an award for
innovation it's a revolution for the
industry because it can perform several
processes at once that previously
required many different tools it can
assemble and diagnose in one step
cutting time by twenty-five percent and
tires even have their place in the art
world Mirko Cro flow Dean constructed
this tiger from parts and old tires
maybe it will go on to become the new
mascot for the S entire fair
this karmann ghia RS is the only one of
its kind it's part Volkswagen part
Porsche and a whole lot of fun
jochen Badr took the sporty body of a
1970 karmann ghia and pumped it full of
porsche technology the result was a
hybrid that's second to none
mutter tells us that he got the
six-cylinder engine for cheap it had
power despair was intact and durable so
he thought he'd build a car around it he
knew the mortar wouldn't fit into a VW
Beetle but then he thought of the Carmen
and realized it'd be a perfect fit no
the FISC stove as a dark I need mr.
would you like to go for a ride I'll get
my hat that chance is the comedy
originally the Karmann Ghia was a tame
little coupe a with a 50 horsepower
engine in its original condition it
wasn't suited to life in the fast lane
still in the 1960s the little Volkswagen
proved a hit with women only two but
after yahan badr had finishing pimping
it the tame little ghia went wild now
his four-decade ovw delivers the
performance of a modern portion the 321
horsepower 3.6 liter cc engine can
propel the car to a top speed of more
than 300 kilometers an hour the ghia had
good aerodynamics from the start now
even modern-day sports cars have to make
way for butters karmann ghia RS he's
used to the stunt looks
Potter says even when he overtakes a
Porsche or Daimler the drivers are
enthused and get a laugh out of it the
feedbacks all positive people give him
the thumbs up and tell him it's cool
that a car like this can go so fast so
motor than are specified you think the
mechanical design engineer spent four
years creating his karmann ghia hybrid
but he couldn't have done it without the
assistance of stefan dentling and on da
escola to automotive engineering
students they helped him with the
chassis the brakes and the aerodynamics
and even wrote their theses on the car
the VW Beetle platform is often proved a
good basis for modifications or
reconstructions and the Karmann Ghia
which was produced from nineteen fifty
six to nineteen seventy-four also
employed Volkswagen technology well it
looks sporty the series production 2+2
cedar was hardly a speed demon its
engine produced his 50 horsepower at
best and the ghia couldn't go over 140
kilometers an hour still the model
proved a hit over 400,000 rolled off the
assembly lines at carmens Factory in
osnabrück before its successor the
Scirocco went into production in 1974
with the exception of the 18-inch wheels
jochen bothers dia looks pretty much the
same as the series production model
though on closer inspection you can see
the steel roll cage through the rear
window otherwise jochen bata has
remained true to his motto why draw
attention to yourself unnecessarily the
most flamboyant part of the car is found
under the hood an air-cooled 6-cylinder
boxer engine from the Porsche 993 after
undergoing various modifications the 3.6
liter motor produces a whopping 321
horsepower and that distinctive porsche
sound too
the interior is very minimalist jochen
Badr has integrated a tube frame into
the Karman body to improve stability and
safety this framework supports all of
the porsche technology hidden underneath
the VW body are the front and rear axles
of a Porsche 944 turbo the car has cost
him plenty of money and sleepless nights
but for yahan bada it was all worth the
effort
for anything he says for as long as he
can remember people have dreamed of
being the wolf in sheep's clothing it
started in the 70s with the beetle but
it's harder with the new generation of
cars like the Gulf which are already
fast he feels it's boring just to make
them go faster no one gives a hoot about
that but take a 40 year old car like
this which no one thinks can do over a
hundred he says then it's something when
you're doing 200 klicks and shift into
fifth gear knowing you still have a 16
th pay rates fire window the ocean front
rather than the novel on 16 Yavin bother
shows us just what the car can do on a
stretch of road that's been blocked off
he loves to push the car to its limits
and doesn't much care what purist think
of his Porsche powered creation his
karmann ghia RS is a one-of-a-kind
creation that runs circles around the
rest
you
you